un point terrain en Ukraine à présent
l'Ukraine de nouveau la cible d'une
attaque russe la nuit dernière Kiev dit
avoir été visé par 33 drones des engins
de conception iranienne ass sur l'armée
ukrainienne qui fait état de 22 missiles
abattu alors que la France vous le savez
a réitéré son aide à à l'Ukraine ces
derniers jours la France qui se dit
prête à financer 12 nouveaux canons
César on va retrouver tout de suite sur
le terrain au plus près des combats
Guliver craque bonjour Guliver vous vous
trouvez dans la région de de doniesque
dans le Dombas quelles sont les les
nouvelles du terrain
aujourd'hui alors je suis dans une
tranchée d'entraînement où des soldats
qui sont là depuis plusieurs mois affine
leurs compétences une formation continue
si vous voulez ces soldats ont
visiblement le moral encore assez haut
ils sont de bonne humeur mais ils disent
qu'ils sont fatigués qu'ils ont envie
d'avoir la possib ibil de faire une
pause tout le monde parle de la
nécessité de recruter plus de monde il y
a cette loi sur la mobilisation qui doit
être passé à Kiev ici les soldats disent
que ils devrait miser plus sur le
recrutement attirer les gens justement
par la promesse d'une formation de
qualité de bonne communication avec les
supérieurs quant à la situation sur la
ligne de front il est décrivent comme
stable mais difficile c'est-à-dire que
les Russes maintiennent la pression sur
toute la ligne de front la situation est
difficile c'est les Russes qui ont
l'initiative mais pour le moment
l'Ukraine ne subit pas de perte
territoriale majeur arrivrive à à
défendre la ligne mais ils disent que
cela pourrait changer j'ai demandé
notamment s'il y avait un risque de
perdre avdivka et les soldats ici ont
dit que si euh le soutien occidental et
les armes diminuent il y aurait de vrais
risques donc toutes ces rencontres à
l'internationale des leaders Ukrainiens
sont perçus comme extrêmement importants
par les soldats ici euh sur le terrain